hey guys this is pearl davis and this is
my youtube channel just pearly things
today i'm going to tell you the story of
how i
accidentally became a promoter in
college
if you like the story don't forget to
like subscribe and comment
okay so where do i start when i was in
college there was a bar
called the snuggery and snuggery was
like it was the funnest literally the
funnest bar like you could sneak in no
matter what age you were
the cool thing about the bars anyone who
doesn't like to like
club super hard but they like to party
you want to find a place with a dj
and a dance floor and you want to find a
place that like
you can still hear people you can still
go talk if that's your thing but if you
want to break it down on the dance floor
you don't want to be the only one doing
it
and this bar was like one of the best
places that i have found to do it
however my senior year something tragic
happened
terrible it was devastating for the
elmhurst college community
my favorite bar my favorite bar in the
entire world shut down
so going into my senior year college
there really wasn't another bar to go to
so i decided to take matters into my own
hands you know i'm
i'm not about to let my senior year
college be lame
so what i did was i called all the bars
in the area
and i said i'm going to show you the
clip of me doing it
did i remember about one of the most
united communities we have on campus
binge drinkers now the community of
albus college binge drinkers are looking
for a place to go on saturday nights
and i'd like to talk to some of the
managers in the area
to discuss the possibility of when and
where dj we could find a dj and a dance
floor
to break it down if you could call me
back
i'd really appreciate the opportunity to
discuss this
possibility thank you i am another
valued member of the elmhurst college
community
known as fringe drinkers and i am
very um unaware of why there might be a
policy
that only the dj comes for the first
saturday of the month
um we are we are ready to party we are
ready to
hashtag break it down on saturday nights
and
we would love for snuggery or aka
cottage hill
to come back with dj saturday nights so
that we can unite
and just absolutely get drunk um please
consider this option thank you
and i wasn't trying to make any money
off of this i was just trying to get
drunk honestly
yeah i was just trying to break it down
you know i was just trying to have a
good time
things changed things changed fast so
basically i i finally i
call a bunch of bars and some people
didn't call me back some people said no
i finally got one guy's place called
crazy port and villa park
he said yeah let's do it i'm like
yes and i end up like that saturday like
i posted on pages whatever
i was just trying to find a place for me
to party like i wasn't trying to do
anything i didn't want to drive like to
downtown chicago to parties it was like
30 minutes from chicago and i don't know
how many people showed up
probably like 500 people at least
like all because of me this is me no one
had ever been to that bar before
after that like i got to bring in my own
dj i got to pick like the times they
started
and after that like it was crazy like
they paid me
to drink like they literally paid me
like i could go to the bar
i got free drinks and then they would
pay me like money at the end of the
night if i brought my friends
and then i could also i was in charge of
the promotions i was in charge
literally everything it was fun i had to
walk away though honestly because
you know sometimes in life free drinking
leads to gaining like 30 pounds and it
took me like two years to lose it so
yeah
i had to i had to walk away but that's
how i became
a promoter in college by accident